[موسيقى]
قبل ان نجلس بحلب
طلعتنا ما كانت مبرمجه كان اجتهاد شخصي من
عندي
يعني مراحل الخروج كنت انا اللي اجتهد
وكنت انا ورانا لحالنا واولادنا انا اللي
اجتهد انه هسه نطلع هسه نترك هذا المكان
هسه نروح للمكان الفلاني يا ريتها كانت
مبرمجه ومنظمه انه ما كانت سهله اطلاقا
لكن كيف انتم بنات صدام حسين والبلد يعني
عليها ضربات عسكريه معقول ان لم
يبلغوكم انه عليكم ان تذهبوا الى المكان
الفلاني او لا
[موسيقى]
اتجهت باتجاه السيء بسرعه
كبيره الى الدرجه اللي فرطت الامور كحكم
فرط الحكم
فما صارت الخيارات المطروحه كثيرا امامنا
لكن دائما كانوا يتطمنون علينا ونتواصل
معهم
[موسيقى]
اخذت القرار على انه لازم نغادر
رغم انه طرحوا يعني خيارين عليه قالوا لي
اما رجعك للموصل نضمك بين عشائرنا
او تطلعين السوريه قلت له ولا خطوه ما
ارجع الى
الخلف لا
طبعا لم يكن القرار سهل لانه احنا
والسوريين ما كنا على ود ما نقول اعداء
احنا ما عندنا عدويه اخوتنا بس لم يكن
بالعلاقه ودياني قررت انه اطلع لماذا
اخترت سوريا حتى تكون اول محطه لمغادره
البلد لان هي يعني اسهل الدخول الها وانه
احنا عفوا ما عندنا جوازات ما عندنا
جوازات سفر العائله فلازم نطلع بطريقه غير
الاهتمام يعني مو كل الشرعيه دخلنا يسموه
تهريب
صدام حسين دخلنا تهريب دخل التهريب مشينا
على رجلينا
[موسيقى]